Brett Kavanaugh will hear his first
arguments this morning as the newest
Supreme Court justice he promised to be
impartial at last night's ceremonial
swearing-in at the White House this
follows Cavanaugh's all-out confirmation
battle that led one retired Justice to
say he didn't belong on the High Court
Jen Crawford is outside the Supreme
Court Jan good morning welcome ari so
justice Kavanagh is gonna hear arguments
this morning it's relatively technical
criminal cases and what's already a
quiet term so far unlike that
confirmation process which say the least
was a political firestorm the Senate
confirmation process was contentious and
emotional that process is over my focus
now is to be the best justice I can be
addressing the public and the eight
justices he will soon join justice Brett
Kavanaugh promise to treat everyone with
fairness I was not appointed to serve
one party or one interest but to serve
one nation it was a sharp contrast to
last month's hearing when he turned his
focus to Democrats while rejecting
accusations of sexual assault
this whole two-week effort has been a
calculated and orchestrated political
hit before watching his second Supreme
Court justice being sworn in President
Trump claimed the confirmation process
proved Kavanaugh was innocent of the
allegations but a last-minute FBI
inquiry approved by the White House and
Republicans on the Senate Judiciary
Committee did not conclude Cavanaugh's
innocence or guilt on behalf of our
nation I want to apologize to Brett and
the entire Cavanaugh family for the
terrible pain and suffering you have
been forced to endure Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell also in the audience
said earlier in the day that Cavanaugh
is Confirmation united the Republican
base ahead of the midterm elections what
I think this has done for us is provide
the kind of adrenaline shot that we had
not been able to figure out how to
achieve in any other way now justice
Cavanaugh is also making good on a
pledge he made back in the beginning of
this whole process all four
if his law clerks are women that is a
first for the Supreme Court and listen
to this four of the other female clerks
who are working here this term for other
justices had clerked for Justice
Kavanaugh when he was on the federal
appeals court John was making a history
already Jan the quiet term isn't gonna
stay quiet long it's now got a
conservative lean when do we think we'll
see the impact of Kavanagh on this court
well join us you know Justice Kennedy
was a conservative but he sided with
liberals on some of those social issue
cases and those normally don't come out
until the very end of the term in June
so it might be awhile and we don't know
really what's going to happen they say a
new justice will make a new Court so
justices can rethink their ideological
alliances and their positions who knows
I mean the Chief Justice summer
speculated could now become the next
swing vote all right Jan reporting live
from the Supreme Court thank you and he
said last night that his daughters were
getting the day off from school so they
could be there for the first day I
thought that was my sister I'm late on
them nicest family that's been hard on
everybody else thank you again Jan